[Music]
anti-semitism mental health disorders
legal troubles as it turns out many of
the cast members of netflix's hit sci-fi
series stranger things have had their
share of hardships what's the story
behind these tragic details keep
watching to find out
sometimes an actor's talent is
unmistakable that became clear for
millie bobby brown when she broke out as
a star of stranger things in the first
season while her peers in the cast were
largely playing typically rambunctious
young boys brown was tasked with
portraying a very different young girl
named simply 11 brown's character never
obtained a normal education when she
escaped the horrors of the lab she was
raised in she was shaken to her core
living in a world she simply didn't
recognize or understand brown made us
believe that l was truly a laboratory
guinea pig lost somewhere beyond her
cage
who are you in trouble with
bad
apparently brown's parents had a great
amount of faith in their daughter and
her talent according to the daily mail
it sold nearly all of their possessions
so they could move their daughter to los
angeles and give her the exposure she
needed the family didn't have much and
nearly entered bankruptcy brown's
manager even loaned them some money to
help them get by a gamble that paid off
when stranger things rocketed the young
actor to stardom
since making an impression in his
breakout role as mike wheeler finn
wolfhard has become a heavily
sought-after talent in hollywood as his
star rose to fame he joined big budget
projects such as 2017's it and 2021's
ghostbusters afterlife clearly wolfhard
has a penchant for starring in 80s era
nostalgia trips
out for summer
on stranger things mike became something
of a leader among his small band of
friends and ultimately 11's love
interest as well as a fan favorite
wolfhard's journey to stardom didn't
come without a few struggles in talking
with the washington post he revealed how
difficult it had been to maintain his
normal teenage friends and balance life
as an actor furthermore he had the ugly
task of firing his agent in 2017 after
hearing of multiple sexual misconduct
allegations levied against the man
despite the upheaval wolfhard states
that it was one of the easiest decisions
he's ever had to make he explained he
was abusing his power when it comes to
something like that you can't be
personal clearly no amount of stardom
will keep him from having a good head on
his shoulders
winona ryder has been a fixture of
cinema since her days as a young star
sharing the scream with michael keaton's
beetlejuice after her torrid rise in the
80s and early 90s ryder largely receded
from the spotlight for several years
more recently she's made something of a
comeback largely buoyed by her casting
in stranger things
[Music]
are you alive
[Music]
ryder's career has had more ups and
downs but it certainly hasn't been
without its darker moments including her
experiences with anti-semitism she's
talked about being subjected to remarks
about her appearance with one studio
head claiming that she quote looked too
jewish to be in a blue-blooded family in
writer's experience comments of this
nature was sadly par for the course
rider's family history has a remarkably
dark cloud hanging over it including
family members who died in nazi
concentration camps during world war ii
while she doesn't consider herself
religious her heritage is precious and
her painful family history is ever
present in her life and if the
anti-semitism isn't bad enough she's
also been told by casting directors that
she simply isn't pretty enough to be an
actress which is just hilariously false
look at me now
i get to date joyce myers oh are you
kidding me
everybody loves dustin really what's not
to love he's playful witty and
incredibly brilliant when it comes to
figuring out this whole upside down
business gate in matarazzo the young
actor behind the character exudes a
charm and charisma that seems to just be
a part of who he is why are you
listening to the music steve listen to
the russian we're translating russian
unbeknownst to many matarazzo has lived
with a condition known as clydocranial
dysplasia or ccd which affects bone and
teeth growth as a result the actor has
experienced a lisp and stunted growth
that impacted his ability to land acting
roles until stranger things came along
in fact dustin's missing teeth in the
first season is because of ccd the
showrunners actually incorporated
matarazzo's condition into the
development of his character matarazu
has continued raising awareness for the
condition and has even worked with the
non-profit organization ccd smiles in an
effort to raise money for those affected
by it if stranger things has any
indication he has a bright future ahead
of him
the ruffencruft former police chief jim
hobber is brought to life by actor david
harbour who landed an early big break at
the turn of the century as a recurring
character offers a shanks on as the
world turns he soon started making small
appearances in big screen hits such as
brokeback mountain and quantum of solace
before landing bigger parts in movies
like the green hornet and black widow he
was also tapped to play the comic book
hero hellboy in the 2019 franchise
reboot
[Music]
hey
i'm on your side
throughout this rise to stardom harbour
has learned to live with and manage his
bipolar diagnosis in an interview with
npr he mentioned how he was
institutionalized in his mid-twenties
before receiving a clear diagnosis and
undergoing treatment harbour has gone on
to talk about his anxiety over his
medication affecting his acting
capabilities candidly opening up about
the diagnosis as an example of success
for those who fear living with the
disorder he hopes to have more candid
discussions about bipolar disorder
helping others understand that a
person's capabilities aren't necessarily
defined by their mental illness jonathan
byers played by charlie heaton is
fiercely protective of his family his
dedication to protecting those he cares
about draws the interest of nancy
wheeler an attraction that's been
mirrored in real life as the two actors
are actually an item
what if i just
don't let you go
he's part of a massively successful tv
series but he turned still run into his
fair share of trouble in 2017 just
before the premiere of season two of
stranger things he was denied entry into
the united states after authorities
allegedly found a small amount of
cocaine in his luggage he was absent
from the premiere as a result the actor
has maintained that he was never charged
with a crime as he told flaunt magazine
it was hard everything happened so fast
but they hadn't come to term to the fact
that i was famous and something steps in
from the work you are doing and breaks
into your personal life you feel kind of
vulnerable despite that issue heaton
hasn't missed the beat as jonathan
continues combating all the
monstrosities he upside down throws his
way
maya hawk daughter of ethan hawk and uma
thurman had access to the best advice in
the world when it comes to breaking into
the industry in her role as robin on
stranger things she serves as a voice of
reason when hanging around steve and
discovering the horrors of the upside
down i don't understand what happened to
that car l has superpowers i'm sorry
super power she threw it with her mind
come on catch up as capable as hawk is
she didn't always have the confidence to
pursue an acting career she revealed to
the sydney morning herald that she
struggled with dyslexia growing up
recounting that she bounced around from
school to school hoping to find the
right place during this period she found
inspiration from her favorite literary
works especially little women hawk went
on to play joe march in a 2017
adaptation of the novel the kinship she
felt was joe is vibrantly expressed in
the character's sense of wonder and
determination she finally landed in a
school that encouraged creative
expression which is where hawke gained
an appreciation for drama and acting
stranger things fans everywhere are
grateful robin simply wouldn't be the
same with althorg playing the character
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]